is North Korea mad at us again I'm glad
you're here today there was something
this morning that I was reading what
happened North Korea's angry so they do
cycles North Korea so they'll do good
cop bad cop and we saw this happen it
was just really amazing so North Korea
has this weapon that causes everyone on
earth to have amnesia about that River
really angry so as tensions as US
tensions rise right so they have this
weapon that caused everyone to have
amnesia right so they'll do something
and that people forget what happened six
months ago when the Singapore summit was
happening and they were making nice and
everyone's just like Oh blah blah I go
last year they had sentenced President
Trump to death they were threatening to
nuke Guam and everyone just complete
forgot about that
and then like okay we're gonna be nice
it's like and then he cancels the summit
the summit comes back on their it they
do this they've done this for years and
it's like if you followed North Korea's
I do it's my gig you see it coming but
then everyone's like oh my god they're
mad at us this has never happened before
like this has happened for 70 years
[ __ ] this is their stick mm-hmm
so what do you think the purpose of it
is just to stay relevant in the news and
to alert people that there's still
conflict between the u.s. it's very
important for them when they make any
sort of concessions to say that they're
we're putting up a fight we're not we're
doing this because we want to not
because you're making us doing it
standing up for themselves we're not
going to get pushed around because they
can't show submission or weakness in any
sense so president Trump's been playing
this very intelligently and the rest
then and the corporate press won't tell
you this because everything's about
Trump I don't [ __ ] care about Trump
in this context I care what the North
Korean people right the point is they
are they'll rip their Radle their saber
and then they'll be nice the next day
and then they rattle the saber in their
nights next day it's it's it's as a
night follows day with them well the
cultures of really fascinating culture
the culture of Korea in general yeah you
know it's there's there's so much to it
that we have a really difficult time
understanding oh yes in terms of just
the formalities in which you're allowed
to communicate with people the way that
they must save face right and what
they're doing any
there there's any sort of negotiation
there has to be some sort of an
acknowledgement of their social status
right in their position yeah yeah
they're very bad South Korea too so
people think South Korea is like America
Junior it's not they're a very different
country from us and just because they're
our Ally doesn't mean they're all good
guys too I was just reading Malcolm
Gladwell's outliers
okay yeah I'm one of the things about it
is how South Korea dealt with they went
through a crisis of plane crashes and
one of the problems the plane crashes
was the way the subordinates were not
allowed to question the pilot when the
pilots were tired you know the way they
fixed it they made them all speak
English how would that fix it because
English is a different the structure of
the syntax the structure of politeness
and deferment and all the different
things that reduces the way you're not
allowed to communicate with people in
Korean where there's a very strong
tradition of sit like the the Malcolm
Gladwell goes into it in great detail
like superiors when they're around their
subordinates the subordinates are not
allowed to drink in front of them they
can't smoke in front of them they have
to turn away if they have a drink in
front of them like there's the the way
they talk to them they bow to them they
they call them sir and I went through
all this in Taekwondo Taekwondo is very
structured that way and when I was
teaching and when I was when I was
working for my Korean instructor it's
like it was always sir it was only have
Mr Kim it was always very formal
there was always bowing and it was there
was you know and this is an Americanized
version right English right with their
language with the Korean language they
were talking about all the different
proper forms of communication and the
structure that's in place to establish
who the dominant person is and who the
subordinate person and in North Korea
there's a tense that they use only with
regards to the leaders yeah so they've
changed the language that extent even
for them yeah so what they did was they
made the South Korean pilots like all of
them English was the primary language of
communication they had to learn English
now and they had to learn on their own
oh there to learn English and then I
think they went with first names so we
and would work together I wouldn't say
mr. malice like because then I would
have I would be to support yeah yeah
yeah yeah I would say Mike we got some
frost on the wing in this plane we
should probably defrost this [ __ ] and
you and I would be even though you would
be the captain I would be your co-pilot
we would still be able to talk to each
other as if we're friends and equals not
on this traditional Korean social
structure